[Music]
another regeneration milestone was
celebrated recently as large crowds
gathered for the official opening of the
kuiper river view terraces and boardwalk
with Mayor David ears cutting the ribbon
Thank You exemplifying what we're trying
to do to the regeneration program not
simply repair what was broken during the
earthquakes could actually take a car
pulley another step forward the opening
was timed to coincide with the return of
the kayakoy River carnival and Boat Show
we haven't had a river carnival since
around about the 90s and it's really
good to see activity on the river again
and of course that's what this
redevelopment of this part of carp was
all about and getting people back on to
the river a huge amount of work was
completed in recent months to get the
terraces Reedy wooden decking was laid a
competition winning poem was installed
and moldy design elements were
sandblasted and to the stairs down by
the new Coast Guard building dredging
was completed to allow for the
installation of the first pontoon a
second larger pontoon will be installed
between the river view terraces and
wharf later this year and with the
adjacent commercial development now also
open highboys marine precinct are
starting to take on a life of its own
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]